No,
you saw the same thing with social knits
and his description of the gulags
because they were running in large part
by the inmates,
but I think that that's a really good
metaphor for totalitarian states in
general,
you know,
because we like to think that a
totalitarian state is made up of
innocent,
oppressed individuals who are under the
thumb of a,
uh,
an evil tyrant and that all of the
catastrophes are cascading from the top
down.
But I don't think that that's true.
I think that it's more like a
holographic structure where the tyranny
exists at every single level.
So it exists psychologically and it
exists within the family and it exists
within the mid level organizations.
And so,
well,
you know,
when eastern Germany for example,
one out of every three people was a
government informer.
So what that meant is if you had a
family of six people,
that two of them you couldn't trust and
you can't,
you can't just say that.
That's a consequence of the top down
structure.
It.
Tyranny is something that exists
everywhere simultaneously.
Once it,
once it gets a grip and it's easy for
people to say things like,
well,
I was just following orders and you
know,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to put myself in a
position where I'm claiming that if I
was in that position,
I wouldn't have followed orders in the
same way.
I mean,
God only knows until you get there.
Right?
That's for sure.
But,
but what that did to me was focused my
attention more and more on,
on,
uh,
the necessity of individual
responsibility.
I thought if it was individuals in the
final analysis who were responsible for
the great evils of the 20th century,
which I think is a reasonable way of
conceptualizing it,
then it might be individuals who could
be responsible for whatever good there
might be in mankind that could help us
avoid those situations in the future.
And I thought of that as an alternative
in some sense to nihilistic disbelief
and ideological possession,
you know,
because if your group identity is too
tight,
then you start acting like they like,
they a,
like,
like a,
like a cog in a mob.
Not so very bad thing.
But then if your group identity
disappears completely,
well then you're left alone and bereft,
and so those are bad alternatives,
right?
You're sort of damned if you do and
damned if you don't.
And it it was.
It was very difficult to understand that
there might be a third path between
those two.
I couldn't see the,
the existence of anything because people
need belief systems in order to exist,
right?
To maintain psychological stability and
domain.
So maintain sociological stability as
well.
But then if the beliefs get too rigid,
then they turn into a raging
totalitarian mob.
So maybe you let that go because you
don't want to play that game,
but then you dissolve because you have
no identity.
That's not,
that's not acceptable either.
When I first laid that out,
that clearly it was really hard on me
because I couldn't see a third path to
that.
But then I started to realize,
and this was a consequence of reading
the sorts of things that we already
talked about,
but also starting to understand the
underlying structure of mythology and
what a heroic path man essentially.
And that meant adoption of supreme moral
responsibility as an individual.
Now there's,
there's this,
there's this idea in the new testament,
which is a really interesting idea.
You know,
it's,
it's one of these bottomless ideas and I
mean that literally you could study it
forever and never get to the bottom of
it.
And the idea is that Christ is the
person who takes the sins of mankind on
himself and there's something redemptive
about that.
And that's actually a really dark idea
because what it means as far as I can
tell what it means,
at least what it means psychologically
is that when you read these terrible
things,
you have to understand that you're
reading about you.
If you don't understand that you're
reading about you,
then you don't actually understand the
stories,
you know,
because you put yourself in the position
where you're automatically the good
person who would never do anything like
that.
And then these other people are,
while they're devils in some sense,
right?
And it's very easy for people to make
that division,
but it's a horrific realization when you
think that that devil that you see
outside is the same thing that's inside
and that you don't know until you're put
in a situation like that what you might
do.
And then it's even worse because if you
look at the historical evidence,
you know,
um,
it's,
it was ordinary people in some sense
that produced the catastrophes of Nazi
Germany and the Soviet Union and China.
I mean,
they might not have originated it,
but they certainly had the option to say
no at different parts of different steps
along the way.
And they didn't,
you know.
And these things do happen.
One horrible thing at a time.
There's this great book called ordinary
men,
um,
which,
which describes the descent of,
of a German police force from ordinary
bourgeois middleclass men.
Essentially just ordinary policemen who
actually were raised before the Hitler
youth.
They weren't indoctrinated,
you know,
as young people.
Um,
and they were,
they were brought into Poland to sort of
mock pop after the Germans had walked
through.
And it describes how they descended into
the sort of people who would take naked
women out,
naked,
prayed pregnant women out into the
middle of fields and shoot them in the
back of the head.
And what's horrifying about the book is
that the author,
I'm Browning a details,
the stages by which this occurred and
it's,
it's all,
for example,
the commander of this unit told the man
that they were going to have to do
terrible things,
but that they could go home if they
wanted to.
And then you think,
well there's a,
there's an out but,
but then if you really think about it,
you think,
well,
there are tight tightly knit cause a
military organization and one of the
natural thoughts under that circumstance
would be,
well,
I'm not going to leave my comrades to do
all the dirty work.
That would just be a matter of
cowardice.
And so you can see that you know that,
that there's an ethical requirement that
would keep you there to begin with.
And then they were,
you're,
you're doing what you just said.
Which is taking the burden of this
sinful activity on yourself.
If you let everyone else do it,
then you're not,
you're not acting heroically.
Right?
And,
and so it was easy for the men to get
entrapped into that and then you know,
the requirements for their horrific
action kept ramping up and like each
time the accepted the requirement of
doing one horrific thing,
the probability that they would accept
the next requirement increased.
And what is also really interesting
about that book of ordinary men is that
it's not like these men didn't suffer
like they were suffering terribly.
They were physically ill,
they were vomiting,
they were,
they were tearing themselves apart
psychologically,
you know,
but they didn't quit.
So that's a,
that's a great book because if you want
to know how you walk down the how you,
how you can be enticed to walk down a
terrible path.
That's the book to read.
And it's very frightening because if you
read it properly,
then you know,
you have to read it again,
as I said,
is if you're one of the people to whom
this is happening,
not the victim,
but the oppressor,
you know,
and I mean,
you can also read it as the victim.
That's fair enough.
But,
but it's ordinary people who participate
in these things.
And that's very,
very terrifying thought.